something special he will never
forget what about someone special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin Bacon
we're looking for the legendary Kevin Bacon
tracks your voice is small and mousy
I think maybe he didn't hear you yeah
you're coming with us as a Christmas present
Twas the Night Before Christmas oh a set lit so
bright a director was planning an awesome
Delight to make a Marvel special with some
holiday fun that man was none other than
director James Gunn it is the very first
thing ever conceived from Marvel Studios
for Disney plus it's a fantastic story
vomited from the brain of a Mad genius
action on the set of volume two James
Gunn said we should do a holiday special
Merry Christmas we all had a
laugh we thought that would
be great and then they growed it like three days
holiday special it's like awesome
this has been a real joyful shoot
because I get to work with a
lot of people I really love
I think audiences are really going
to be excited it's probably going
to be played every year for the rest of our lives
I've been bacon look come
with us as a Christmas present
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie we have
a brand new Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special trailer so we'll break it down there's a
bunch of new Easter eggs they also talk a little
bit about how they actually came up with making
it obviously it's meant to be a big parody of
the Star Wars holiday special so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
I'll be doing videos for it just like I did for
Marvel's werewolf by night the other big special
presentation went off and obviously this is meant
to be a big prequel for Guardians of the Galaxy 3
so we'll explain how it ties in with the plot of
Guardians 3 and some of the characters they're
introducing during that because there are a
couple of big additions to this like Cosmo
the dog is a much bigger character than we've
seen in the previous Guardians movies I think
the funny Revelation here is the James Gunn came
up with the idea way back when they were filming
Guardians of the Galaxy 2 while they were on set
like that's when he pitched it to Kevin foggy
Kevin feige is like yes he wrote a draft super
quickly and he said that he actually wrote Kevin
Bacon into that first draft and then pitched it
to Kevin Bacon who was also like hell yes I'll
be in that thing but you have to remember this is
years ago when they were filming Guardians of the
Galaxy 2. basically the idea here is that Peter
Quill is super bummed out about the new version
of Gamora from 2014 that he's trying to find
again and get to fall in love with him again
because obviously she never met him because
it's the earlier version of the character so
she hasn't been through any of the things that the
original version of Gamora went through she's not
supposed to be in this but she is a huge character
obviously during Guardians of the Galaxy 3 they're
waiting till Guardians 3 to resolve most of the
plot with that version of Gamora this is meant
to take place the Christmas after Thor love and
thunder which is taking place about three years
after Avengers endgame or so around the same time
that most of black panther wakanda forever happens
in around the same time that Ant-Man the Wasp
Quantumania is happening but that's meant to be
the first Marvel Phase 5 movie so that's actually
probably happening like a little bit after the
holiday season so we'll say it's happening really
early 2024 tentatively unless they say something
different when the movie actually comes out and
a lot of the plot is the Guardians of the Galaxy
trying to figure out one what is Christmas just to
begin with like Christmas is a concept the holiday
celebrations is a concept which is why they use
this particular Tom Petty song on the trailer is
called Christmas time all over again but the joke
is that he's trying to figure out what Christmas
time is during the song like he doesn't understand
Christmas and that's the whole idea with Drax and
mantis is they're trying to grab Kevin Bacon we
don't really know what Christmas is but we're
definitely gonna celebrate it the reason of going
to Joint Kevin Bacon is because they know Peter
Quill loves 80s pop culture 80s music 80s movies
80s everything because that was the time when he
left planet Earth so like all of his pop culture
knowledge is frozen during that era but obviously
because the Footloose joke at the end of the
Footloose movie Kevin Bacon has a dance off to
save the dance hall basically at the end of the
first Guardians of the Galaxy movie he had the
dance off to save the universe and then they
actually had a legit Footloose joke name drop
during Avengers Infinity War so I'm about to dance
off to save the universe what dance off it's not
it's not a it's not I can loose the movie exactly
like Footloose is it still the greatest movie in
history it never was don't encourage this all
right if James Gunn really did come up with
the idea for the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special while they were filming Guardians of the
Galaxy 2 that means he actually intended to pay
off this Kevin Bacon Footloose joke before they
actually wrote the Footloose joke for Avengers
Infinity War even though because of the order
they're releasing things it seems the other way
around it seems like this Kevin Bacon joke in the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special is paying
off the Avengers Infinity War joke technically
it's the other way around but the basic idea
during this is that Kevin Bacon is meant to
be playing a real-life version of himself like
it's the actor Kevin Bacon who made the Footloose
movie but it's inside the MCU I made the X-Men
first Class joke before too because Kevin Bacon
played Sebastian Shaw during X-Men first Class
and if he's the actor Kevin Bacon who made all
these movies that means that the X-Men first
Class movies are technically kind of Canon to
the MCU now Deadpool already canonized all that
stuff to the same Fox Marvel Universe like the
X-Men first Class movies are Canon to the same
original Brian Singer X-Men movies with Patrick
Stewart's Professor X with the same version of
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in those versions will be
the versions that we see in Deadpool 3 and they'll
be coming to the MCU at some point during the
movie thank you very much TVA Loki and Mobius I
just did a big video about that too however crazy
you think that they would get with the cannon
in the Deadpool movie messing around with that
they're gonna get even crazier but eventually
they will wind up in the MCU by the end of that
movie meaning by association the X-Men first Class
movies would be Canon to the MCU so everything is
connected this is a giant meta circle of Easter
eggs confusing you in the best possible way the
planet that Peter Quill and most of the Guardians
are on during most of the holiday special is the
contraxia planet like the pleasure planet that
most of the ravagers stay on between missions
the whole idea is that they technically still
think of themselves as ravagers they just have
new management quote unquote after the events the
Guardians of the Galaxy 2. that actually plays in
with the idea of what's happening during Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 because at the beginning of that
they find out that Gamora like the 2014 version
of Gamora has gone full Thanos and basically
taken over the ravagers so it's like a more badass
version of the character before you saw her meet
up with Peter Quill and turn against Thanos in
the first Guardians movie James Gunn did clarify
a couple things because there's like a much bigger
version of Groot and that's obviously a big point
of Interest like wait a minute is growing to full
size during this or during Guardians of the Galaxy
3 because there was a moment during my Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 trailer video where we actually
see him hook out like a Groot hook out type of
moment where he gets super big they released an
early Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer back at
Comic-Con I've already done a full breakdown of
that all the new footage in the new Easter eggs so
I'll post a link for that at the end of this and
down in the description below because we do get
our first genuine look at Adam Warlock during that
he's not supposed to appear during the holiday
special just during Guardians 3. and the big
thing with Groot during this yes he is bigger it's
like he has grown quite a bit but when I watched
the first trailer I actually thought that they
did him as a practical effect just in the tone
of the Star Wars holiday special like doing it is
kind of like a funny in-joke kind of thing like
we'll make him look super low-fi because that was
kind of the vibe of the Star Wars holiday special
but James Gunn actually said that they did Groot
the way that they usually do him like as a full on
special effect they just made him look practical
using special effects it's kind of the same thing
that they did with the Marvel Werewolf By Night
holiday special making it black and white like
intentionally making it seem kind of old timey
even though they're using really really modern
special effects I'm sure a bunch of people will
watch the holiday special and be like why does
it look so Lo-Fi like no no they're actually
using their super expensive special effects to
make it look Lo-Fi because they're going with
the vibe of the Star Wars holiday special but
there are probably all kinds of young people who
have never seen the Star Wars holiday special if
you haven't seen it you should at least check out
some of it if you can make this as a whole thing
you are a champ it is genuinely not great like
Mark Hamill makes fun of it all the time on his
Twitter account if you never watched it George
Lucas famously created it just to sell toys and
it aired to the CBS special presentation which
is what inspired the Marvel special presentation
whole branding in the logo like that's based on
the Star Wars holiday special special presentation
because it was a real quick and dirty kind of
commercial just to sell toys none of the actors
wanted to be in it have asked my associate
and me to present the Star Wars collection
the remarkable toys and games for your children
Harrison Ford went crazy when he found out he had
to be in it but contractually he was forced to
do it it features the very first appearance of
Boba Fett I've already talked about that during
all my Mandalorian videos back during season one
and after it was done it accomplished what it
was supposed to do like Star Wars toys sold like
crazy it's where George Lucas made most of his
money in all the merchandising around Star Wars
not the actual films themselves but even though
financially it wound up being very successful for
him in the long run George Lucas famously hated
the production so much that it only aired that
one time November 1978 and he used his power
to basically kill all copies of it so that it
could never air again but so much time has gone
by since it actually aired it's kind of passed
into pop culture Legend like hey remember that
crazy Star Wars holiday special let's put that
back up again I'm sure there'll still be a lot of
people watching the holiday special next week not
really understanding why they're going with that
Vibe or what's really going on with it the same
thing happened when Marvel's werewolf By Night
came out and it was black and white meant to be
in the same Vibe as the classic Universal monster
movies the 1930s a lot of people just hadn't seen
those classic monster movies and didn't really
understand the whole black and white Vibe like
no no this is actually a Masterwork this is
amazing it's meant to be Low-Fi on purpose I've
already talked a little bit about Cosmo the dog
she is going to be a character during Guardians
3 so they're kind of introducing her in a bigger
way or re-introducing her during this special in
the comics Cosmo was based on the real-life
Russian space dog Laika in the 1950s Russia
tested some of their space technology using a dog
the dog was fired into space and eventually wound
up dying in the comics the same thing happened
to Cosmo but when she was fired into space went
to Nowhere got bombarded with cosmic rays and
gained the ability to talk so it's Cosmo the
talking dog so during the special you'll hear her
voice for the first time and it's being played by
Maria Bakalova. Michael Rooker was also listed
in the cast of this so he probably has a cameo
as yondu in some way either like a flashback
or some funny cut to of earlier footage or
just like a hallucination that Peter Quill is
having there's not supposed to be any kind of
Thor Chris Hemsworth Cameo or anything thing like
that they might reference the events of Thor love
and thunder just to help with continuity and like
I said Adam Warlock isn't supposed to be in this
I think Guardians 3 is supposed to be the first
time we actually see him on screen I'm allowed
to post my review next week so look out for that
in my full breakdown Easter eggs video all that
stuff will post after it actually comes out next
Friday everyone click here for my Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 trailer video and Easter eggs and
click here for my brand new Deadpool 3 trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!